getting from A to B has never been more
exciting than it was in 2015 so we've
got Wired's top 5 transportation stories
of the year for you in at number 5 the
118 hours Swiss pilot Andre Borschberg
spent in a solar-powered plane traveling
across the Pacific Ocean Borschberg
flight from Japan to Hawaii was a huge
step in and around the world trip
designed to make people rethink the
possibility of sustainable aviation
story number 4 has to be the fact that
only one American metropolis is among
the 20 most bike-friendly cities on the
planet of course Europe dominated the
rankings with Copenhagen and amsterdam
ranked at number one and number two the
sole American representative was
Minneapolis in at number 18 the third
biggest story of 2015 Tesla's launch of
its long-awaited model x SUV the
follow-up to the much-loved to model as
is gorgeous futuristic and chose Tesla
is the company redefining electric
driving and at number two VW cheating on
emissions tests in what could be the
biggest car scandal in years VW was
caught out by the EPA for cheating smog
testing through sophisticated smart wear
devices installed on half a million
diesel cars just in the u.s. it saw the
CEO fired in VW stocks plummet but the
long-term damage to the brand is
immeasurable but without a doubt the
biggest story of 2015 has been the rise
of the self-driving car Google Audi
Daimler Tesla and others all made big
strides this year in developing
autonomous technology proofing its
capability on the highway and
surprisingly complicated suburban
streets we're still a few years out from
letting go of the wheel altogether but
this year has marked the beginning of a
new world